[Musique]
madureira berceau de la culture noire à
rio de janeiro un quartier populaire au
coeur de la zone nord comme une grande
partie de la communauté congolaise c'est
ici que vivait moïse kaba gambe et 24
ans fin janvier le jeune homme a été
brutalement assassinée roué de coups par
au moins trois zones après une dispute
devant le kiosque de plage où il
travaillait
depuis ce jour là daniel le cousin de
moïse se bat avec sa famille pour
obtenir justice après avoir reçu des
menaces ils vivent désormais cloître et
je n'arrive plus à rien faire j'ai peur
de ce qu'il peut m'arriver là dehors
je sens que si je sors je peux être tué
comme mon frère hugo amèrement
yvonne a fui la guerre civile au congo
et pensées se sentir en sécurité au
brésil où 56 % de la population et noir
sont me suis dit j'ai fait mais s'attire
libre parce qu'il a des noirs est l'un
des métis il ya une place
je vais être
mais c'est tout l'inversé qui s'est
produit selon le dernier atlas des
violences en 2019 au brésil 77% des
victimes d'homicides étaient noirs ici
pour daniel les personnes noires
originaires d'afrique subissent une
double peine il ya une discrimination
non seulement des noirs mais une
discrimination aussi des étrangers j'ai
à travailler dans plusieurs endroits
plusieurs entreprises des fois pour
annette j'essaie quelqu'un d'inférieur
il ya certaines choses que tu ne peux
pas
en signe de protestation ce jour là sur
la plage de barra da tijuca quartier
huppé de rio de janeiro des milliers de
manifestants se sont rassemblés sur les
lieux du crime devant le kiosque où
moïse travail est
là faire grandement médiatisée a
rassemblé bien plus que ce que la
famille de moïse espérer
au-delà du crime xénophobe c'est le
racisme profondément ancré dans la
société brésilienne que ces manifestants
sont venus dénoncer
nous sommes unis aujourd'hui parce que
ce qui a tué moïse nous tuent tous les
jours de toutes les façons le racisme à
la brésilienne lazer nos phobies les
fascistes au pouvoir mais nous allons
les renverser nous sommes ici pour créer
les viennois recompte et arrêtez de nous
tuer
des crimes régulièrement dénoncé ici à
l'ordre des avocats de rio rodrigo
montego défend la famille de moïse et
bien d'autres dans son bureau les
dossiers s'empilent
parce que malheureusement ici un cas à
part est plus un autre et ils sont tous
urgent aucun dossier n'est simple
ce qu'expose ici cet avocat c'est un
racisme qui continuent de structurer
l'ordre social malgré les lois qui le
condamne le pays marqué par
l'esclavagisme se targuait pourtant
depuis des décennies de recevoir à bras
ouverts toutes les nationalités et de
respecter toutes les couleurs de peau un
mythe démenti chaque jour par rodrigo et
ses collègues
l'état donne la priorité à certains
crimes ceux commis contre des personnes
blanches sont traités avec sérieux quand
ils sont commis contre des personnes
noires les enquêtes sont beaucoup plus
lentes
presque tous les juges au brésil sont
blancs et issus de familles riches
en analysant une affaire ils ressentent
beaucoup plus d'empathie pour leurs
semblables que pour une personne qui est
différente
oui
des injustices à répétition presque au
même moment un autre crime raciste
viennent endeuiller rio alors qu'il
rentrait chez lui durval teofilo père de
famille de 38 ans a été abattu de trois
balles par son voisin un militaire blanc
qui dit l'avoir pris pour un voleur
un homicide d'abord qualifié d'
involontaire une décision qui a fait
scandale avant que le caractère
intentionnel ne soit finalement retenu
dans les charges
3 0 de saint mathieu du staff à
l'occasion radio dans sa minute a cure
l'etarra
guitare la profitation
une histoire qui semble encore trop
commune dans un pays où le racisme
structurel continue de faire des
victimes rien qu'à rio ces 35 dernières
années moins de 300 procès pour injure
et crimes racistes ont donné suite à des
condamnations
[Musique]